So you can keep the ways to deal
with shoddy connectivity for free.
It doesn't cover every situation though.
For example,
you're probably very judicious about
cleaning up listeners
in Shopping Lists++.
This means that when a user
navigates away from a screen,
the listener is probably cleaned up.
This is great for
memory performance, but
it also flushes our local cache of data.
So say you're online and it shows
you your lists, then you go offline.
Changes you do on that
screen are saved locally
while you're looking at the data.
But when you navigate away
from an activity in them back,
It actually won't display the data
because we destroyed the listener.
The solution though is not to remove
our clean-up code for listeners.
Instead, there are two other options
that you should be aware of to leverage
what is saved in
the local Firebase cache.
They are setPersistenceEnabled,
and keepSynced.
setPersistenceEnable keeps
any data you download from the database
around in the local cache.
This would solve the problem I mentioned
before with cleaning up listeners.
It also saves data between
restarts of the app.
Let's say you're shopping for
a very, very long time.
You've been recording all these
purchases you're making and
then your phone runs out of battery and
shuts off, closing the app.
If you didn't use setPersistenceEnabled,
any data that wasn't sent to
the server isn't saved for free.
Since setPersistenceEnabled is so
useful, you might be wondering
when you shouldn't use it.
There are two downsides to using
separate setPersistenceEnabled.
It does use more disk space
to store your data locally.
Another downside is that if you
were offline and used lots of
addListenersForSingleValueEvent, it
will query the local storage if offline.
If you then come online,
it will not query the database again.
This makes it possible to show
old data to your user and
can create tricky bugs to find.
If you want to cache additional
parts of the database
that you don't have listeners for, the
method keepsSynced is available to you.
For example consider this.
You're a user and you load up
your list of shopping lists but
you haven't clicked on any
specific shopping list.
Imagine you go offline.
And then select one of these lists.
What will you see?
You'll see a shopping
list with no items.
You never had a listener for
these items.
So the local cache will
not of save these items.
Using keepSynced though, you could
explicitly say listen to this data, and
it will keep the data sync locally.
Then, if a user clicks on a shopping
list, even when you're offline,
you'd see the items when you open up the
activity and the state of those items
would match what they looked like
the instant the app went offline.
Again, the downside of using keepSynced
is the amount of data you store locally.
Even though these methods use a little
extra memory, they are important to know
about so you can keep the most important
screens of your app working seamlessly
for users, even in flakey
connectivity or offline situations.